it's like if you contact guerrillas
enough times then they start reacting to
your presence rather than only avoiding
you and running away with fear if you do
that they get a bit angry then you lose
them and then for like two weeks you
don't find them anymore
after you found them again you have to
start all over again
Chloe tries to contact the guerrillas
everyday but even after five years it
can still take hours just to find them
this guy is bad Sam
is bad so somebody wants this way the
trackers start making a special noise to
let the guerillas know it's us Lima
Matata ending believe me they know the
clucking very well and if you don't do
it they think you were someone coming to
kill them we know we're close but where
are they you can actually smell the
silver back it's probably strong to
stink
so really close even from 15 feet away
it's nearly impossible to see them
then something goes wrong Sam is
chilling we've gotten too close we sit
tight all I know is that it
what guerrillas were coming out of
everywhere I just just went down as
quickly as I could I didn't see my Gary
every direction I thought there was a
gorilla coming out oh and then I saw him
duck down and I was like home duck and
right back down with them clearly
agitated
Malema charges it seems he'd prefer that
we weren't around
[Music]